how old is that that is 440 grams so
she's a pouch baby wrapped in a knitted
pouch this tiny koala is something of a
miracle baby her mother is dead killed
in the recent Australian bushfires
weighing less than half a bag of sugar
baby Hays was rescued by firefighters
she was very ill when she arrived in
fact I didn't think that she'd probably
survive she's one of 25 koalas being
cared for by volunteers Kristine and
Paul McLeod in their home in New South
Wales there's no way she can survive on
her own
this is Sparky news from the Harrington
fire this room on the side of the house
has been transformed into a critical
care ward Sparky's been here for around
two weeks what's what injuries did he
have then a pause nose singed fur but he
was on the edge of the park so he was
able to escape out into the green
section the fires burning here have been
some of the biggest of the past week
nine injured koalas have been brought in
over the last few days alone but some
are so badly burned they're being
transferred to clinics outside the fire
zone what makes a quality CLE at risk
from these fires because other animals
will run out of the fire zone koalas
will go to the top of the tree so if
you've got a crown fire
you're going to have an incinerated
koala so I think we've got five five
little juveniles ready to go and it's
not just injured koalas being affected
this group was due to be released but
their habitat has been decimated there's
nowhere safe to go with fires still
burning it's difficult to gauge the full
impact on New South Wales koala
population but here they fear it could
be catastrophic these might be the
insurance policy the next generation do
you think it's that stark I do I do
yeah yeah virtually could be the only
ones left out of that whole population
it's feared at least 350 koalas have
already died
it and with more than a hundred fires
still burning that number is likely to
rise
Siobhan Robbins Sky News Australia